if only someone had given Nick Fury the
same kind of warning Santa Claus once
gave Ralphie Parker kid ever since
samuel l.jackson revealed in January
2018 that Captain Marvel would feature
fury without his signature eyepatch fans
everywhere have been wondering the same
thing with the newest MCU entry explain
how he actually lost his I Jackson in
the whole Captain Marvel team including
star brie Larson and co-director Zanna
Bowden and Ryan flecked have kept quiet
about that particular element of the
film but now we know the truth Captain
Marvel does indeed see fury sustain the
injury that ultimately costs him his eye
in doing so the film also answers a
mystery that's gone unsolved for 11
years since the debut of Iron Man in the
beginning of the MCU as we know it
spoilers ahead obviously so here's what
happens with fury and his infamous AI in
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers best friend
and fellow Air Force pilot Maria Rambo
boards a ship with fury after evading
the Kree Star Force we're actually the
main bad guys in the film
unbeknownst to Maria and fury goofs the
fuzzy orange cat Fury often cuddled with
and queued at throughout the duration of
Captain Marvel is in tow as well it's
worth noting here that goose isn't
actually a cat he's a flirt c'n an alien
creature who only takes on a feline
appearance and it's goose who plays a
big part in getting Fury and company to
safety during the film's final act when
he realizes the cat has made his way
onto his ship Fury scoops goofs up and
thanks him for helping them on their
mission to save Earth protecting the
shape-shifting scrolls and retrieving
the tesseract as Maria and fury attempt
to escape the Kree goose opens his mouth
and extends several octopus-like arms to
grab the tesseract and swallow it whole
luckily goose has a pocket dimension in
which he's able to store entire
universes and access them at will
naturally fury believes goose would
never hurt him since he's on their side
as fury delivers baby talk to goose the
cat takes a swipe at his face leaving
several scratch marks across Fury's
eyebrow and lid fury and Maria assumed
that the scratch is nothing major but
the injury only gets worse as the film
wraps up by the very end of the movie we
see fury wearing a metallic looking
cover over the injured eye agent Phil
Coulson steps into Fury's office hands
him a case full of fake guys and
jokes that he has a big decision to make
he then asks if it's true that the Cree
burned Fury's eye out a rumor fury
neither confirmed nor denied signaling
that he's learned to stay cautious of
everyone around him after his
life-changing adventures with Captain
Marvel the Kree and the Skrulls the
injury fury suffers and Captain Marvel
also connects nicely to the only
explicit statement fury has given about
his eye and the MCU thus far fans have
wondered what happened to Fury's eye
since we first met him in Iron Man but
he's only ever made one direct mention
of it though the someone fury trusted is
really a something that mystery is
finally solved fury trusted goose to be
a friendly companion thanked him for his
role in completing the mission and
eventually needs to wear an eyepatch for
the rest of his life because of it a cat
like alien probably isn't the
untrustworthy entity fans were thinking
of when fury first spoke about losing
his eye but it's now officially canon in
the MCU check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite Marvel movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]